Ang responsableng computing ay nauunawaan
bilang pagbuo ng quantum computing
nang may kamalayan sa kapangyarihan nito
at mga potensyal na epekto kapag sinabi nating responsable
kailangan nating bumuo at gumamit ng teknolohiya
batay sa mga paunang itinakdang prinsipyo para tulungan tayong maiwasan
at mapigilan ang mga potensyal na pinsala
habang nagtataguyod ng mga solusyong proaktibo
na inklusibo at mapanagutan sa IBM
pinatnubayan kami ng pakiramdam ng responsibilidad
sa lipunan sa loob ng maraming dekada ngayon tinatawag namin ang aming sarili na isang catalyst
na nagpapabuti ng mundo ibig sabihin
mayroon kaming responsibilidad na isaalang-alang ang mga implikasyon ng
mga teknolohiyang binubuo namin at tinutulungang gamitin
habang binubuo namin ang bagong teknolohiyang ito
ang mga desisyon na gagawin natin ngayon ay makakaimpluwensya sa hinaharap
at ang mga desisyong ito
ay may potensyal na magkaroon ng malaking epekto sa lipunan
halimbawa maaari kang magdesisyon kung hahabulin ang isang aplikasyon
na tumutulong sa iilang stakeholder lamang o
isa na maaaring malutas ng isang suliranin sa lipunan
umaasa kami na ikaw bilang kliyente ay makapag-iisip
tungkol sa responsableng pagbuo ng quantum computing para
ang pag-iisip nang responsable ay makatutulong sa iyong negosyong makabuo ng tiwala
sa mga mamumuhunan at mga consumer
habang nagtatayo rin ng reputasyon ng integridad
at paghanga mula sa iyong mga empleyado
at mga customer sa kabilang banda
makakatulong ito na maprotektahan ka mula sa masamang publisidad mga multa
at mga parusa sa video na ito
ipakikilala namin ang mahahalagang konsiderasyon sa responsibilidad
na tatalakayin sa iyong koponan
habang pinagaaralan mo ang quantum computing
at ang mga aplikasyon nito pagdating sa quantum computing
ang pag-iisip at pagkilos nang responsable
ay nangangahulugang pagsunod sa isang hanay ng mga prinsipyo
at mga halaga upang gabayan ang iyong pagbuo
at deployment ng teknolohiya
halimbawa nangangahulugan ito ng pagiging transparent
tungkol sa parehong mga limitasyon at kakayahan
ng quantum computing ngayon mayroon kaming wika
sa aming mga kontrata na nag-aatas sa mga kliyente ng IBM Quantum
na gamitin ang aming mga sistema nang responsable
at hindi gamitin ang aming mga sistema
para sa mga masama o ilegal na layunin
tinatawag namin ito na aming responsableng paggamit
at mga sugnay ng katanggap-tanggap na paggamit
ang wikang ito ay nakakaimpluwensya na sa pag-iisip ng aming mga kliyente
tungkol sa pagbuo ng quantum
para sa kanilang mga use case maaari rin
tayong makatulong na maimpluwensyahan ang direksyon ng quantum computing
sa pamamagitan ng pagpili kung aling mga aplikasyon ang hahabulin natin
para sa pagbuo at acceleration
upang maprotektahan laban sa mga potensyal na di-responsableng paggamit
ng aming teknolohiya bumuo rin kami ng matibay na IBM Quantum
safe na teknolohiya habang iniisip mo kung paano
at para saan gagamitin ang quantum computing
tiyaking magsalita nang makatotohanan tungkol sa iyong mga inaasahan
para sa quantum computing at ang mga timeline
kung kailan mo inaasahang isasama ang quantum
huwag ipakita ang quantum computing
bilang misteryoso sa halip subukang ipaliwanag ito nang makatotohanan
bilang hardware ng computing
na sumusunod sa mga patakaran ng quantum physics
tiyaking ang iyong use case para sa quantum computing
ay proaktibong inklusibo
at isinasaalang-alang ang lahat ng potensyal na stakeholder
upang matukoy ang lawak
ng anumang negatibong epekto sa lipunan
tiyaking natukoy mo ang malinaw na mga prinsipyo
at mga halaga para sa iyong paggalugad ng use case
at pagbuo salamat
sa iyong panonood umaasa kami na
habang dinadala mo ang kapaki-pakinabang na quantum computing sa mundo
iisipin mo rin kung paano mo ito magagawa nang responsable.
Ang ang